[Music]
hello everyone
in the previous lecture we were
discussing about virtual displacements
and usually when we come across this
virtual displacements in certain
textbooks
oftentimes we see that the next topic is
the principle of virtual work because of
course it is
intrinsically connected to the concept
of virtual displacements however
there is a missing link in terms of
the requirement or the motivation of
considering
the principle of virtual work so
what we'll do is we'll we'll discuss the
principle of virtual work
certainly but before that we will
discuss something which is all very
familiar to us
and uh through that discussion we'll see
what is the motivation for discussing
the principle of virtual work
all right so
the first thing we are going to discuss
is uh the law of kinetic energy which
you all know but nevertheless i will
discuss it
so uh in in our
in in the in the lecture notes that i
share with you uh
the formal statement of this thing is
given
so i will not rewrite it again but i'll
just discuss it here
and the law of kinetic energy it tells
us that
the work done by all the forces
and mind you when i say all the forces i
include all the external
as well as the internal forces that act
on a mechanical system
so the work of all these external and
internal forces that act on a mechanical
system
it equals the increase of kinetic energy
of the system of that mechanical system
this is what the law of kinetic energy
is telling us
so how can we put that in in terms of
some equations
so so you please note that uh
this is very important
before writing an equation that
the work done that is involved
is due to both
internal and internal forces
and that is equal to the increase
in the kinetic energy okay so i've
written in a very informal fashion here
so uh the work done
on a mechanical system uh
between the times t naught and t one
so we'll consider it to be like this so
usually uh
we are familiar with this kind of an
expression f
dot d r where d r is
the infinitesimal displacement
up but uh
there are certain disadvantages to
writing like this
okay uh i mean it can be quite a
detailed discussion
uh i won't go into that much detail
so you think about this
okay so think about this part i will not
write like dr
vectored and if you have some doubts we
can discuss it during our
now clearing sessions so instead of this
what i will do is i will write it like
v dt okay so with the understanding
that v
is
like this okay but it makes
quite a bit of difference when we write
in this alternative fashion
now
this f vector we can write it like mass
times the rate of change of the velocity
which you all know from our uh from our
basic principles of mechanics
and this
this entire thing can be written
as half m
d dt of v
dot v do you understand what is going on
here
so this is uh so if you do a
uh to a chain rule decomposition of this
derivative you will end up with twice of
this term so which is why we have the
half here
so overall what we obtain
is something like this
okay and you understand that this entire
entity
overall is nothing but the change in the
kinetic energy
all right so uh
so this is this is just the statement of
the law of kinetic energy written in
terms of um of the variables involved
but this is not the end of it we have to
understand a few
uh very important points associated with
it
so the first thing that we have to note
is that the law of kinetic energy
so
the law of kinetic energy uh it is
restricted
to
[Music]
inertial frames of reference this is
very important to note
to inertial frames of reference
now you can understand that in different
inertial frames of reference
the the accounting of the kinetic energy
will be different because the velocities
may be different
which means that uh
with changes of the inertial frames of
reference with the choice of the initial
frames of reference
the the work done associated with the
kinetic energy
that also changes with value okay
so this is not an implication of the law
of kinetic energy but this is something
that you have to remember when
i've been talking about the law of
kinetic energy
okay next
what is the implication of this law of
kinetic energy so
as i said the whole point of discussing
this law of kinetic energy
is to motivate ultimately the discussion
of the
principle of virtual work so how do we
make that
step how do we proceed towards that so
as a first step we have to
we need to appreciate that as a direct
implication of this law of kinetic
energy we can think
that when a mechanical system is
beginning to move
okay then certainly it is gaining
kinetic energy so
[Music]
mechanical system begins to move
which implies that the kinetic energy is
increasing
now by directly from the law of kinetic
energy what we can say
is that the work done
by all the external and internal forces
on this mechanical system
when this delta k is increasing that
work done must also be
positive okay so
okay work done due to external
and internal forces must also
be positive so can we not
conclude from this that
uh for a mechanical system
up so when we are considering this
mechanical system it is not going to
move spontaneously
unless uh it experiences some kind of
arbitrarily small displacement
in such a fashion that the work done by
all the external and internal forces
is positive i repeat the implication of
what we have just said here that the
when a mechanical system begins to move
the kinetic energy is increasing
and as a result of that we have to
conclude that the work done on it
must also be positive by the law of
kinetic energy
so in other words what we can say is
that a mechanical system
will not spontaneously start to move
unless the unless it is
unless for some arbitrarily small
displacement
i mean it it the arbitrary small
displacement has to be in such a fashion
that the work done
by all the external and internal forces
is positive
okay so it's just different way of
looking at things but it has a
tremendous implication
okay and that implication is uh
captured in uh what is referred to
as the fouriers inequality now this
fourier's inequality is something which
we don't often come across in our
undergraduate textbooks of mechanics
but uh historically it has an important
place
now and it is something which is the
precursor to the
principle of virtual work now before we
uh discuss
quickly the fourier's inequality uh let
me just tell you that
when i when i mentioned that a
mechanical system it does not
spontaneously move unless for arbitrary
small displacements
you have to understand that all those
displacements that we think about for
this
for this mechanical system
if you take your uh if you take your
conceptual understanding back to what we
are discussing
uh in our previous lectures of energy
methods we can think of them
as changes in configuration and mind you
those changes in configuration can be
brought about
by virtual inventional displacements
okay
so as long as we proceed by
admissible paths respecting the
constraints
of the system we are free to explore
various different configurations okay so
you take a configuration you take a sort
of neighborhood configuration
going by an admissible path uh
so when i say thing like that i
basically mean that
you are imposing a virtual displacement
a virtual
infinitesimal displacement on it and
then thinking about
the kind of work done that is involved
whether it is positive or what
okay so so so the implication of this
law of kinetic energy it can be summed
up in the
the something called the fouriers
inequality
that is the next topic here
and what the fouriers inequality it
tells us okay again i am not going to
write the statement here the formal
statement because that is
already written in our lecture notes so
now what it is
what tells us is that a motionless
mechanical system
it remains at rest okay motionless
mechanical system it remains at rest
if the virtual work done by all the
external internal forces that is very
important
just like in the law of kinetic energy
it is less than
or equal to zero for every small
virtual displacement that is consistent
with the constraints okay so
just to capture the important points of
this emotionless mechanical system
remains at rest
in the virtual work
so uh you can uh somebody can
point out that we have not really gone
into the principle of virtual work so
why are we
stating something like virtual work so
uh
you understand that this is just the
work done associated with
a virtual displacement which have which
we have
already talked about in detail in the in
the previous
uh video the emotionless mechanical
system it remains at risk of the virtual
work
done by done by all
internal and internal forces
is less than equal to zero okay
so that's it now uh
in in more concrete terms beyond this
abstract
statements you consider the the simple
example of
a break resting on a table okay
so you think of it like this that we
have a break
on a table now uh
suppose we imagine that this
brick it slides a little bit either to
the left or the
other or either the left or the or to
the right
so uh friction
will perform negative work okay
so why do we say negative because uh you
understand that the direction
of uh of the friction force will be
opposite to the motion of this break
okay so the work uh done on this on this
break
is going to be negative now
uh
so that that is directly connected with
what we have here
okay so uh because it is less than equal
to zero
that work done by the friction so uh
what we were thinking about as a
possibility of motion
uh is certainly not it certainly not a
possibility
so as far as friction goes this
motionless break
will continue to remain at rest okay so
there is no danger
that friction will automatically
initiate some kind of
motion of this this break which of
course you all know intuitively
okay so of course a brick which is
resting like this is certainly not going
to be initiated into motion because of
the friction
rather the friction returns the any any
possibility of motion
okay next example is that uh
suppose you imagine that this break
it spontaneously tilts like that okay so
instead of like that it may be just on
one end of it just lifts up
in that case also uh the
force of gravity will perform a negative
work on this
and so that kind of a virtual
displacement we are thinking of
uh that
that will imply a negative virtual work
and so
from the point of view of gravity also
this motionless mechanical system
it remains at rest again you think of
uh so i'll not go into the the detailed
uh discussion of this but i'm just
telling you that suppose
you imagine that this breaks just hops
like that
and comes back then what happens
okay so
my question is whether the work done is
negative or zero so you think about it
and you'll get your answer
okay so the answer of course the
ultimate answer is that that kind of a
hop is also
uh an impossibility which you know
physically
because if you think about physically
spontaneously it's certainly not going
to hop like that
but in terms of the fourier's inequality
also that kind of emotion
is certainly prevented okay but now
there is a subtlety a very important
subtlety
uh involved with this fourier's
inequality and that subtlety is that
whatever inequality we are talking about
here that
the virtual work done by all the
external internal forces is less than
zero
that is only a sufficient condition
meaning that if we find okay
so fourier's inequality
is only a sufficient condition
so if you find out that
the work done by all the external
internal forces for
a virtual small displacement is less
than equal to zero
then it is guaranteed that the
motionless mechanical system will remain
at risk there is no problem with it
however if you find that this
inequality is violated then you cannot
conclude necessarily
that the body cannot be at equilibrium
okay so let me repeat that if you find
that the work done by all the
forces an internal is less than equal to
zero then you are guaranteed
is sufficient to sufficient for us to uh
for that uh
it's sufficient for us uh to conclude
that
the motionless mechanical system will
remain at rest however if we find that
this inequality is violated
for example if we find that
for a certain kind of motion the
the virtual work done by all the
external internal forces is
greater than 0 then we we cannot
conclude
for sure that the motionless mechanical
system cannot be
uh cannot indeed be in equilibrium okay
so
the the example which uh which is
usually given for
uh to illustrate this thing is we take a
dome like this
and you place a little marble here okay
now you know that this marble or this
little ball
is in a state of equilibrium at the top
position of this
dome okay it's not a stable
equilibrium but it is an equilibrium
condition okay so
what happens is that if you slightly
perturb it
it will just drop off from here so in
terms of the virtual displacement if you
if you if you
displace it very by very little amount
here
then it may uh appear like
the work done by by the force of gravity
it will turn out to be
positive so this fourier's inequality is
violated
and that may tempt us to conclude that
this thing
is certainly not in equilibrium but that
would be a wrong conclusion
because uh this position is very much in
equilibrium it's not a stable
equilibrium but that's a different story
but it is in equilibrium now this kind
of an inequal
uh like a violation of the inequality
takes place because
of uh some issues with uh
with the orders at which we are
calculating the work done so there are
certain certainties involved which
i'm not going into right now uh
but the fact remains that the fourier's
inequality only gives us a sufficient
condition
it does not give us a necessary
condition so it would be very much
useful for us to obtain a condition
for equilibrium which is both necessary
as well as
sufficient okay so this is not necessary
this inequality is not necessary so we
would like to find out
okay so this is the main uh
outcome of all this discussion that we
would like to find
some condition
that is both
necessary
and sufficient
it is this condition it is our quest for
such a condition which leads us
to the principle of virtual work because
that principle of virtual work will
will end will be giving us both a
necessary
and a sufficient condition all right so
in the in the next video i'll conclude
the video here so in the next video we
are going to discuss the principle of
virtual work
but before we discuss that principle of
virtual work uh we'll have to discuss
a a little uh
a little extra thing which is called the
uh the work function okay so there's a
subtlety involved there also so
we'll discuss that okay in the
subsequent lectures all right thank you
very much